okay level with me who do you think of
when i say the word sentinels most of
you probably think of their weeby
wonderkid tens arguably the most
mechanically gifted valoret player on
the planet but tins and company holding
on but the response from cloud9 has been
swift as well but since it's gonna go
all the way for the ace you have to be
kidding me or maybe you think of shazam
the big brain igl behind the team's
success i love these retakes 5v5 spike
planet you hardly ever see this oh can
you get to see how the util is perfectly
used to retake the site
that's what he needs to get the rolling
excuse me to run it back hence what the
operator gets one stick once again
showing the efficacy of that ultimate
the spike is going to start to confuse
dapper sticking on its own continues to
stick the matter to faze sentinels are
on that point a flawless round maybe
some of you think of dapper teabagging
his opponent's lifeless bodies or sick
clutching up round after round can stick
find the first player yes he can there
goes lakia a right click on the paint
shell sick nails the clutch 1v2 no
problem at all for him but you probably
don't think about this guy
look down look down you go under it no
you can't then you go under it limbo
limbo look down
[Laughter]
meet jared zombs gitlin the monotone
mastermind who might just be the heart
of sentinel's championship roster zombs
is one of the greatest support players
in valorant pulling the strings behind
the scenes on astra and viper and while
some teams have struggled to keep up
with riot's meta altering updates
sentinels have continued to dominate
because of zom's willingness to flex
into nearly any role uh nah i definitely
prefer this meta right now but it's
mainly it's probably because the other
teams just aren't as good as us at it
and i think like me and dapper both
enjoy playing viper so and i think i'm
probably the best astro in the game so
it works out so how exactly did a shy
quiet guy like zombs become valorent's
most godly support player and more
importantly how has his selfless nature
helped sentinels to become the best
valorant team in the world the one was
close they don't know oh my god he gets
blessed the team flash the team flash
magnum's in the smoke here oh my god
magnum's got no hp not like this
sentinels they're gonna get the defuse
they've done it sentinels are the
masters to reikovic champions
[Music]
all right so before he boasted the most
prize winnings of any single
professional valorant player what was
sentinel's 22 year old catatonically
chilled out controller player up to well
growing up in south florida zombs was
first introduced to gaming at the age of
8 when he caught his stepbrothers
playing the team fortress 2 beta zombs
watched them play tf2 and eventually
counter-strike source before deciding to
give both games a try for himself but
what really interested him were free to
play shooters i was playing so many
random different like free to play
shooter games like dirty bomb soldier
front apb reloaded like
so many random different games like that
now zombs played all of these games off
and on but in october 2015 he dropped
everything when he decided to try out
blizzard's new hero shooter overwatch
zombs quickly established himself as a
top dps player in the beta a role you
wouldn't expect from him given his chill
personality but team liquid took notice
of zom's skills and signed him
immediately tanks which cloud9 is
currently running and it's certainly
working out for them so far as we've
been watching zombs go ham with that
mccree pistol i don't even know how he
sees the head shots that he's hitting
sometimes third and fourth are gonna run
circles around him and that's what we're
seeing right now sticky on to kai kai
full damage from zombies great play
there i think that was a sticky to the
face it looks like it landed in the face
junkrat's aware the sniper here is aware
oh dodgy back and forth but it's not
enough to dodge zombies two kills very
quick onto river and river is a great
counter sniper so that is definitely a
credit to zombs but his time on liquid
was cut short and after some contract
negotiations fell through
he decided to start his own team but
zombs wasn't just playing overwatch
competitively in his spare time he was
streaming the game on twitch and showing
off his always calm chilled out
personality his new team we united were
a pretty solid roster competing against
some of the best teams in the scene at
the time and eventually faze clan took
notice signing them in august 2016.
zombs found moderate success on faze
over the next year but when the
inaugural season of the overwatch league
was announced he knew he had to secure a
spot on a top roster but just when he
thought he had found his new home
everything came crashing down i like
stopped trying out for other teams and i
was gonna to join cloud9 spitfire and i
was screaming with them for like two to
three months and like the coaches said
they're gonna sign me
like jack followed me on twitter like
they offered me like a contract just to
get paid until the overwatch league
contracts open and then like like midway
through like the signing almost towards
the end of like the signing window for
overwatch league they just like picked
up korean rosters without telling anyone
like we found out through twitter and
they're just like okay well
we we're all now
after getting strung along by c9 zombs
spent the next year competing in the
overwatch contenders league and even
with the self-destruct by zombs they
still should be decent here zombs gets
two but the tanks of simplicity are they
actually gonna pull this back after
sugarfree was pulling by week to victory
that just might be the case for way in
from the back rotations have been made
sky fox is now diving on in retsy still
there and zombies gonna find two
but dps players were a dime a dozen so
he found it nearly impossible to break
into a tier 1 overwatch league roster
after opportunities with the boston
uprising and atlanta reign fell through
zomba's future in overwatch was
uncertain he no longer wanted to compete
in the tier 2 scene so in march 2019 he
dropped the game entirely but he didn't
just retire because he was bored with
overwatch no zombs found something
better
kodai squad wins again nearing the end
of his competitive overwatch career
zombs began playing apex legends and
sentinels took notice pretty quickly
signing him to their roster i was like
i'm either gonna like sit in contenders
like forever like doing nothing or i can
just be on a tier one oregon apex so i
was like apex is fun i'm just going to
try playing apex see where it goes zombs
and his teammates rezzy and sanox were
the first players to reach the coveted
apex predator rank viewers were treated
to a sermon of sorts where zombs would
clap kids and he was frankly disgusting
he felt he fell cracked
dead
right there here i'll tell you what he's
pushing yeah
wait we won baby
let's go
meanwhile sentinels were among the top
rosters in apex constantly placing in
the top three at events and as he
climbed to the top of the pro scene
zomb's viewership was also on the rise
but despite finding success zombs didn't
just have eyes for apex legends in april
2020 he jumped ship to valorant you see
although zombs enjoyed playing apex
playing battle royales for a living
wasn't exactly financially stable and
after seeing how riot handled their
league of legends esports scene he knew
that he wanted to take the chance on
valorent yeah well i mean that's just an
easy choice it's like apex isn't gonna
go anywhere in the future like anywhere
chris is not gonna like
blow up my career in any way or
something like it was just like an
obvious choice that like riot games and
valorem was gonna be better for my
career anyways so it was just an easy
decision there plus i mean switching to
valerian's like an instant like two
times pay raise but zombs didn't
gravitate to the flashier valorant
agents instead he decided to play the
exact role that you might have always
expected a guy like zombs to play
support
see unlike in cs go where everyone has
the exact same utility valarance smokes
and flashes are typically locked to a
certain type of agent and zombs decided
to play the controller role for the team
essentially the smoke roll now if you've
ever played valorant you might have
realized that at least in matchmaking
no one wants to play smokes it's not a
particularly flashy thing to do which is
why you don't have competition for
playing agents like brimstone omen or
astra hell playing astra is like playing
a [ __ ] rts game instead of an fps but
despite being a dps player in overwatch
and an absolute animal in apex
invalorant zombs finally took on a role
that was a little closer to his actual
personality plus it was a role he needed
to play if he wanted to win
barely any players even now play smokes
like in ranked i've never seen anyone
pick smokes on my team like i i have to
pick it if i didn't pick smokes no one
would ever pick smoke alongside his
friend shazam zombs grinded in the beta
the two of them played csgo matchmaking
together back in the day and by the end
of the month they were signed with
sentinel's new valorant roster now once
sentinels started competing they won
just about every tournament they entered
but even after winning ignition series
and masters 1 it seemed the fans always
forgot that zombs existed but when his
teammates appeared on plant chat they
reminded everyone that he's quietly the
most important member of the team that's
obviously zombs astra literally you
could have them he could probably be the
most impactful player on the server
without actually like shooting also like
we're like comfortable leaving him to
anchor site and he's just gonna find a
way with a specter to get two kills yeah
yeah no he's he's nutty he plays more
with spectre than any player i've seen i
mean he wants it yeah
actually he constantly
gives people's guns and they buy me a
spectator
he always always he's there's a reason
he always has a spectator is he's
dropping other people's guns and taking
spectate but even with a significantly
worse weapon zombs often manages to pull
off some incredible stuff his ability to
absolutely frag out with a spectre is
simply unmatched zom single-handedly
holds down sights for sentinels and wins
them rounds that they honestly have no
business winning i'm dead
what's happened i hit 105 on stage on
the right how does he get two kills off
that dapper long range with that spectre
gonna be able to get 146
hp left on celsius dapper
zombies holy [ __ ] that was amazing
your specter's so good yeah i mean i
don't mind being a support player i mean
i'll just sit there and do it every year
i don't really care as long as we're
winning we're winning so
it's fine and then it's working and
zombs did keep winning sentinels
dominated valoran's first international
land in reykjavik iceland where zombs
proved that he isn't just the best
support player in na but the entire
world zombs and his team steamrolled the
competition beating everyone without
dropping a single map but of course he
didn't pop off in typical zomb's fashion
he just hoisted the trophy with one
finger while his team celebrated the win
just another day at the office zombs
finally for you this is a game valerant
a scene that has brought players around
from all different game types yourself
included overwatch apex i want to first
get a little bit of a sense of what the
transition was like for you as a player
from one scene to another yeah i mean
it's pretty easy for me i'm i'm just
insane at every fps any new game that
comes out i'll be pro whatever you know
you know how it is all right but okay
you just stick around in valorem for a
bit will ya we'll see what happens after
dominating the valorant world with
sentinels for over a year zombs is
finally starting to get the recognition
he deserves every great team needs a
player like him someone who's willing to
do whatever it takes to win and anytime
zombs pops off his legion of fans are
waiting at the ready to spam zombs
nation and twitch chat just like they
did in his apex days zombs has always
been the chill monotone guy popping off
no matter what game he was playing but
in valorent it seems like he's finally
embraced his easy going personality he's
the game's ultimate support player and
even though he isn't in every highlight
reel zombs doesn't need to be flashy to
dominate because when his team needs him
most he's always there holding things
down for zom's nation pushing in you
have to approach this map that way
because it's so big and because there's
so many different things to control
oh my gosh oh my god zombs
zombs with foremost down exit
many of you have heard of video games
but there's a new fad that's growing
among young people so-called
e-sports you see kids
it would be interesting to see how much
like long-hair related incidents have
gone up i need to get you i need you to
get me those pictures of pikachu first
of all if there are aliens flying around
the galaxy with advanced technology
they're into lots of stuff okay they're
not they're not going to be puritans
secondly
for archival purposes
uh my mental state is not good